será un gobierno sin precedentes en la
historia de Israel
Pues de alguna manera sí porque como
usted lo decía es el gobierno que tiene
una orientación más
derechista y extremista desde la
fundación del estado de Israel eso pues
no es una noticia que sorprende por
cuanto los aliados de netan Yahoo y su
propio partido licut pues venían
mostrándose
en ascenso en las encuestas Y pues el
resultado es este verdad Un gobierno que
Integra a sectores de la extrema derecha
religiosa y que como en el caso de el
partido del sionismo religioso dirigido
por y tamarven
pues se trata de personas que han
incitado al odio al racismo que han
apelado a la expulsión de los ciudadanos
palestinos de Israel que son el
aproximadamente el 20% de la población y
frente a esto
es la salida de un sector de la
izquierda importante dentro de la
nesseed que era el partido merex que no
alcanza el porcentaje innecesario para
entrar en el parlamento y le deja por
primera vez fuera del mismo lo que
representa pues la eliminación del
último reducto que existía en la
política israelí dentro del llamado
campo de la paz
precisamente ya que usted lo menciona
que podemos esperar sobre el futuro de
las relaciones con los palestinos
Bueno yo creo que la agenda
aneccionista que me están ya fue apoyado
en los últimos años Va a continuar tiene
ya poca resistencia en el parlamento los
partidos árabes
israelíes corrieron separados en la en
la elección y eso pues me envó su peso
dentro de la nessee los sectores que
estarían a favor de un una un
replanteamiento de las negociaciones con
los palestinos no tienen ninguna
incidencia política verdad son fuerzas
marginales dentro del parlamento de
manera que que podemos esperar una
continuación de la de la ocupación y
posiblemente una la decisión en algún
momento de de anexarse
la parte de cisjordania lo cual pues
evidentemente representaría una escalada
del conflicto ahora cuál es el impacto
que podría tener para las regiones de no
estoy nuevo gobierno de Israel
bueno está de elección se da en con un
antecedente importante y es el
acercamiento que ha tenido Israel a
partir de los acuerdos de Abraham con
una serie de petromonarquías del Golfo
Pérsico verdad lo cual
Ah pues ha mejorado su situación
regional verdad pero persiste pues una
situación permanente de tensión con
Siria Pero existe una situación también
de tensión permanente con Líbano verdad
y bueno netanyahu que representa a las
políticas
de Los Halcones en la política israelí
pues eventualmente puede llevar a una a
un nuevo decir ciclo de enfrentamientos
con estos que tienen una relación tensa
con Israel